foreign
hey you guys flickers of fear time once
again
so I know what you guys are probably
thinking
um for somebody who
claims that they don't care all that
much for found footage movies uh I do
kind of seem to talk about them maybe
more than this uh seeming disinterest
would warrant uh but one thing that I am
very interested in is history the
history of horror movies and kind of
like you know the first horror movies to
do certain things like horror movie
Innovation and things like that so
actually I'd been wanting to see this
movie for a very long time because I
heard about it a while back um and you
know it was just going to be like a
matter of time before I got around to
discussing this one because in you know
the context of Horror history this is
actually maybe I don't want to say it
was an important film but it definitely
was like in uh you know an Innovative
one so I kind of wanted to discuss it
and you know see it and talk about it so
I feel like most casual horror fans
Maybe
would probably credit uh The Blair Witch
Project from 1999 for kicking off the
whole found footage phenomenon and I'm
not going to argue with that um you know
obviously it wasn't the first found
footage movie but it was the one that
you know made like the largest cultural
impact and spawned all of the found
footage you know pretty much the whole
genre that we see today
um horror nerds like myself uh will
nitpick that the 1980 Italian
exploitation film Cannibal Holocaust uh
is technically the first movie that
could probably quite comfortably be
found called found footage but amidst
all of this uh one little movie seems to
have gotten a little bit lost in the
shuffle
now it wasn't the first film of its kind
obviously because Cannibal Holocaust got
there first like you know a long time
before almost two decades matter of fact
but it did predate The Blair Witch
Project by almost a year now although
some I think I've seen some like horror
blogs say that it's like this movie was
actually the inspiration for the Blair
Witch Project and that's actually not
the case uh the concept for The Blair
Witch Project was actually kicking
around like as early as 1993. I think
both of these movies were kind of in
production at about roughly the same
time it just happened that this one came
out first I believe it was like 10
months prior to the Blair Witch Project
um so 1998's the Last Broadcast
was actually produced for the pretty
much unheard of some of 900 that is nine
zero zero American dollars and it went
on to gross worldwide about 5 million uh
despite being completely independent
distributed this movie was also rather
notable for being the first
I don't want to call it a widely
released film because it was had a very
very limited release release but it was
kind of like the first somewhat sort of
kind of widely released film that was
shot entirely with consumer grade
digital equipment uh it was actually
even edited on a desktop computer that
was running Adobe Premiere Pro 4.2
and it was the first movie to screen at
limited theaters as I mentioned
completely digitally now because this
was 1998 and the vast majority of movie
theaters were still exclusively set up
for traditional film stock uh this movie
where it played actually had to be shown
via satellite streaming but you know
because it was digital and you know
nowadays I think you know 99 of all
theaters in the United States and
probably the world uh have converted to
digital but in 1998 that was not the
case so this was another way that this
movie was like very much ahead of the
curve like very much on The Cutting Edge
of Technology at the time sadly though
in spite of that uh the lot the last
broadcast was I mean it just had the
misfortune of coming out only like I
said about 10 months before the cultural
Juggernaut that was The Blair Witch
Project which kind of I don't know just
sort of like crushed it beneath the boot
heel of like all the hype that was that
ensued in its wake Now The Last
Broadcast was actually quite difficult
to get hold of for quite a number of
years because like I said it was almost
entirely forgotten but thankfully
nowadays it seems to have been kind of
like rediscovered a little bit
um and as of this recording which is
January 2023 uh both shutter and 2B have
added it to their offerings and you can
also get like a pretty nice uh Blu-ray
that has like a lot of extra features on
it so it is like much easier to access
nowadays now much like The Blair Witch
Project uh The Last Broadcast has kind
of a mockumentary element to it and also
involves a group of people who become
lost in the woods and have something
horrible befall them unlike The Blair
Witch Project though the Last Broadcast
is kind of like a little bit
multi-layered or at least dual layered
it has kind of like a layer like
overlaying the found footage and it also
features a very intriguing murder
mystery angle uh that really kind of
keeps you invested at least it kept me
invested I was really really into like
the whole murder mystery aspect of it I
thought that was really cool and like a
really good idea so the movie is
actually presented as a very low budget
documentary feature made by a filmmaker
named David Lee who's played by a guy
named David beard
now he's examining kind of a well-known
murder case that occurred in 1995 in New
Jersey
now I'm gonna say that like his this guy
like what he's like narrating the
documentary that he's making
um he has this very deep voice and he's
very very intensely serious you can tell
that he's just like trying to give this
some gravitas and him doing that like
really lends this a lot of authenticity
because it comes across very much like
one of those you know overly somber kind
of like those faux weighty TV
documentaries about crime or paranormal
stuff that sort of like littered the
media landscape in the 1970s and 1980s
it was almost kind of like it sounded a
little bit like in search of or like one
of those kind of cheesy documentaries
from like the early 80s or late the late
70s but just his narration really gave
me that Vibe which really kind of like
lented some very similitude so the
incident that he's making this
documentary about
concern two guys whose names were
Stephen Johnny avcast and Locust wheeler
and there actually played those two guys
are played by the filmmakers themselves
who made this film uh Stefan Avalos and
Lance Weiler or wheeler I'm not really
sure how you pronounce his last name so
they these two guys hosted a somewhat
well-known kind of cable access show uh
called fact or fiction which focused on
paranormal subject it was kind of like
one it was like a call-in type of show
now the show uh in the 90s was initially
kind of a cult success but it had
started to wane in popularity somewhat
and so the guys had this idea to kind of
shake things up a little bit by doing a
live simulcast like out in the field
that would center around kind of like
the search for a local Legend now I'm
gonna say in another way that this movie
is kind of ahead of its time the idea of
live streaming from a location is of
course you know ubiquitous nowadays
every every [ __ ] does that but this
was you know the movie was made in 1998
and they're talking about a thing that
happened in 1995
so this would have been quite an
undertaking for them I mean the internet
was still relatively in its infancy and
the concept of streaming a show
simultaneously like over the internet
and cable television like at the same
time was I kind of feel like pretty much
unheard of uh especially for something
like a piddling little cable access show
so the fact that they even put that
concept like in the movie is itself like
way ahead of its time so an anonymous
caller to the show suggests that the
guys go out to the Pine Barrens which is
a real place to look for the Jersey
Devil uh which is a mythical Cryptid um
whose Legend actually it's a real life
it's not a real life monster obviously
but the legend is real uh and I believe
it stretches back to like the 17th
century or something like that
so The Two Hosts Johnny and locusts they
agree that this would be a great idea
like it's right there you know what I
mean so they decide because this is
going to be like a big deal and they're
live streaming and that really hasn't
been done before so they decide they're
gonna recruit a couple of extra hands to
kind of like help them out not only with
the technical aspects of what they're
doing but also the metaphysical aspects
of the investigation and its uh
subsequent broadcast so the two men that
they get to do this are named Rayne
clacken who's played by an actor named
Rain clappers and uh he's a sound guy
whose expertise is kind of like
recording supernatural phenomena I guess
so like EVPs or something and a guy
named uh Jim Seward spelled s-u-e-r-d
who's played by an actor named James
Seward spelled s-e-w-a-r-d
so you know what I mean they're all kind
of using variations of their real names
this guy is a little bit of a weirdo
he's like a self-proclaimed psychic and
he insists that he can kind of advise
them about like the best area to search
for the Jersey Devil in this massive you
know Woods where they're going so
through footage shot by the gang by shot
by these guys and later interviews with
friends and Associates of all of those
principal characters David the guy who's
making this mockumentary that you're
watching uh kind of unfolds The
Narrative for us like talking about this
murder case now as I mentioned this is a
murder case it's a murder mystery and
it's presented as such like very much
like pretty much from the opening
minutes like where the way that the
movie is presented is that I'm making a
documentary about a case that you guys
all know about but I'm showing it like
you know what I mean even though it's
obviously not a real murder case the
audience already knows like from the
beginning of the movie that this
excursion into the pine Barons that
these guys took went horribly horribly
wrong and that only Jim Seward returned
from the woods Locus and Rain were found
viciously murdered and like mutilated
and Johnny was never found at all but
they did find like a whole bunch of his
blood at the scene that suggested that
he was probably killed too because
they're like there's no way that he
could have lived like losing that much
blood
now not long after Jim comes out the
forest he is actually charged with
murdering the other three guys and clips
from the footage that the men shot on
their trip are kind of like used at his
trial like to make him appear kind of
like dangerously unstable and weird and
kind of violent so the mockumentary that
we're watching then made by David the
filmmaker is ostensibly examining the
possibility that Jim Seward was innocent
of these murders and that something else
happened out there in the woods like
were the guys in fact slain by the
Jersey Devil itself like they do kind of
like lean toward that as well like maybe
it was a monster or was maybe something
entirely different going on so the
solution to this mystery starts to
become clearer as a data retrieval
expert named Shelley Monarch who's
played by Michelle Pulaski attempts to
reconstruct some kind of Tangled Up
videotape that David got in a box from
some anonymous source and that may
actually like reveal who the Killer is
because this is supposedly like some
lost footage so David has hired this
expert to kind of like reconstruct and
see if they can put together like what
it is on this film so they can solve the
mystery now I'm not going to spoil the
ending um I know that this movie is you
know 25 years old but I feel like a lot
of people haven't seen it I will note
however that the way that the mystery is
resolved seems to be a big sticking
point with people who didn't
particularly like the movie I have to
say I myself personally I didn't mind it
although I will say that if you think
about if you go back and think about the
logistics of the thing and all of this
other kind of stuff like it doesn't
really make a lot of sense but on the
other hand the solution to the mystery
actually gives the Last Broadcast this
very weirdly like prescient veneer of
metaness you know what I mean that it's
almost kind of like commenting on ways
in which the truth is always very very
slippery and is prone to interpretation
and possibly manipulation by people with
various agendas so I'm just gonna say
conceptually like watching the movie I
actually kind of had a hard time
believing that this was made 25 years
ago I mean aside from I mean obviously
it was made 25 years ago because of like
the very primitive technology and like
the way that it looks but the way like
in regards to his messaging about you
know like the ambiguity of reality as
filtered through media I kind of feel
like it was again like way ahead of its
time and I feel like this is something
that we're still wrestling with nowadays
like to an even more pronounced degree
but the fact that they got so I'm not
saying like the movie's like super deep
or anything like that but but it's just
like interesting from a conceptual
standpoint that they went that far into
it like that far like that far back in
time you know what I mean that they were
thinking along these same lines that
people are still essentially like
talking about in the same way nowadays
now I don't know if I'd say that this
was a better film than the Blair Witch
Project uh it is certainly a more
ambitious one uh in some aspects I
enjoyed it more than the Blair Witch
Project like in various uh for various
reasons and it also impressed me with
like how forward looking it was you know
I mean like how like the um you know the
concepts that it was dealing with I was
also I gotta say like really floored by
how much the filmmakers accomplished for
less than a thousand dollars I mean yeah
the movie looks cheap and very
amateurish but if anything that just
kind of like lends it some credibility
like looking at it you could actually
believe that this was somebody something
that somebody made back in the 1990s
like about a real case like with the
technology available to them so it just
gives it that much and I think even
watching it nowadays like it gives it
even more various military because you
know nowadays people are trying to fake
you know like [ __ ] that was made back in
the 90s this actually was made back in
the 90s
um you know what I mean but I don't know
it just made it seem like a lot more
realistic to me even though it looks
like crap but I mean and I'm not saying
that like in a disparaging way it looks
like crap because [ __ ] back then looked
like crap you know what I mean that's
just how it looked
um the acting performances also were all
very naturalistic and very convincing
um you know and just like they did with
the Blair Witch Project basically all
the actors well like I said two of the
main actors were the filmmakers
themselves so they knew what they wanted
to do
um but the rest of the people were just
giving character outlines and just told
the improvise like I said that's what
they did in Blair Witch Project as well
that's the way that you're gonna get
more more of like a naturalistic
performance uh and like I said I was
also really into the murder mystery
aspect of it which really kind of kept
me interested through the whole uh
movies run time it's not a terribly long
movie it's only about 85 minutes now I
will admit
that I did guess what the twist was
going to be a little bit before it was
revealed but it didn't really bother me
uh you know to any great degree uh your
mileage may vary on that though because
I have seen a lot of people complain
that they thought that the ending ruined
the movie so I don't know how you're
going to feel about that but if you've
seen it like let me know what you
thought about the ending you know what I
mean so I mean if you're at all into
found footage and want to see a very
early entry into the sub-genre that was
for a time almost entirely forgotten you
know just in the long shadow of the
Blair Witch Project uh then by all means
check it out like I said it's on shutter
I believe it's also on 2B for free
um it's legitimately like a big part of
Horror history and you know although
it's a flawed film uh it's definitely
worth seeing and I actually ended up
digging it uh quite a bit so if you've
seen it or if you've even heard of it or
anything like that let me know down in
the comments and that will do it for
this flickers of fear I'll see you guys
again on the next one bye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
thank you